now it's time to switch gears to some of
canada's most beloved stars we're
talking ryan reynolds and katherine
o'hara and
tantu cardinal
who are among some of this year's
laureates who received the governor
general's performing arts awards after a
nearly two-year delay due to the global
health crisis during the virtual
ceremony catherine was given the
lifetime achievement award and received
touching tributes from her shit's creek
co-stars dan levy eugene levy annie
murphy and noah reed who performed a
rendition of joni mitchell's case of you
while wearing some of moira's iconic
wigs
[Music]
on my feet
[Applause]
[Music]
very flattering wow
oh i love katherine herron if you watch
the whole thing she's like crying
throughout that whole performance it was
so well done and it caught me so off
guard the wig changing because
performance was so serious at the
beginning and all of a sudden i was like
his hair different and in the nail
polish
all right well ryan reynolds who was
honored with the national arts center
award received his own musical tribute
courtesy of stephen page which is very
cool who sang an original song about how
much canada loves him he said brian
adams was busy
and nickelback all had to work
they meant to call drake but called me
by mistake till you're stuck with a song
by this jerk
they asked me to write you a number
to show you just how we all feel
we know you're a fan of the
[Music]
canada loves you back
wow
wow that's um
that was stunning
i mean
that made me cry um
well
i guess i've made it
aw
you never actually that song does get
stuck in your head uh aj's saying those
tributes were beautiful loved ryan's
reaction which we usually never see from
him it's true he's always the funny guy
right and you always follow him on
social media to see how liquidity is
even when he trolls his wife i mean i
just love them so much so to see him
really emotionally he's a little bit
speechless yeah it really meant
something to him i love that so much
what did you think of these tributes you
know it's so interesting because i
actually went to the governor's general
awards i guess maybe in 2016 or maybe 17
and there is something so beautiful
celebrating canada and canadians who
have really done something different and
have achieved so much for the country
and ryan reynolds is one of those guys
who
has stepped up in so many ways
especially during culver we've seen him
just you know sharing donations wherever
he could and just he acknowledges
everybody too on social media he has a
way of making sure you know he's
connected and he's he's so brilliant in
his marketing and and he's one of those
canadians that he's always going to be
canadian if that makes sense i know
wherever he goes and he's very proud of
it he's very proud even drake you know
when you think about what he's done as
well amy catherine o'hara um so you know
it is so beautiful to see uh you know
how we celebrated this way and i loved
it i loved it it's just it's a beautiful
moment for canada yeah i agree and it's
really interesting too when you
interview catherine o'hara she's so um
graceful and and it isn't over the top
she's almost kind of shy
and of course you know for so many
people
you know everybody got to know her in
shits creek but it's so funny when you
look back like when i look back at my
childhood and i look at my favorite
films like home alone home alone
the other day my sister's like wait
catherine harris canadian and i was like
yes so it's just so great to see people
who uh have done such fantastic work
great movies that have meant so much to
people and then you have something like
ryan who has given to so many um uh uh
so many um uh hospitals and um groups
that mean something to him he always
shares the wealth and so yeah he's i'm
proud that he's canadian and he ended it
perfectly saying i think you know i feel
like i've made it you know i know wow
it's so so great so beautiful i loved it